[Music]
hello everybody it's monday hopefully
the [ __ ] connection stay i don't know
what the hell is the deal look at that
no we're getting little bits of [ __ ]
red coming in on the stream like it's
slowing down and last yesterday we lost
the end of the show we were pretty much
done anyway i mean we were done talking
about the pursuit i was just kind of
like well i could restart but [ __ ] it i
was just like so sick of it at that
point
you got mad at me uh talking bad about
the movie i'm sure it wasn't that is the
ai we weren't talking about anything and
it was doing red it's already doing red
[ __ ] well it's not doing red [ __ ] right
now but it was when we had that probably
starting soon [ __ ] will later if we lose
the connection and you'll know what
happens well everybody knows what
happens at this point i don't know you
know what it's like it's the 21st
century somebody out here needs to get
their [ __ ] together
and get some good [ __ ] going but then a
few seconds later it'll come back like
yeah
i have a thing that says like to
reconnect it if it goes off uh within so
usually i'll wait like because it'll
blink on and off and i'll be like okay
well if it goes back to green then it's
fine but if it starts going red orange
red orange red orange then i usually
just turn it off if it doesn't come back
but uh you know so hopefully yeah so
this movie right here
this is kind of interesting because this
is one that i saw a lot i think like
back in the late 80s on cable
and i remembered a lot about it like i
remember liking it and then i didn't see
it but then i i didn't see it for a long
time and then i noticed just the other
day that amazon prime had added it and i
put it in the um the patreon poll for
the movie retrospective but it didn't
win
like another one run one which was
actually rituals uh so we got to watch
that one tomorrow night probably yeah
but uh well that made late 80s movie
yeah but last night i was kind of like
man i kind of feel like i'm in the mood
for like re-watching this one
this one i kind of feel like there okay
so there were a lot of movies like this
that came out around this time period i
think like angel heart which came out
serpent and the rainbow this is kind of
like the same vibe as that where it's
just kind of like it's it's not really a
satanic cult per se it's kind of more
like a well it's santeria sort of or
like i guess it's bruja
like a kind of like black magic version
of santeria
um so i kind of feel like there was a
lot of those movies around this time
period and like i said those ones are
kind of the same vibe so it's almost
kind of like
this is
kind of like marginally a horror movie i
guess but it's kind of more like an what
they would call like an occult thriller
i guess
like i said if you like angel heart you
should probably you probably like this
because this is angel heart is a little
bit more fantasy based i feel like
and it's a period piece this one is
actually set in contemporary times i
think these were kind of a more modern
spin-off earlier modern in the late 80s
more like a more modern spin-off of like
uh wicker man
they ended up being the precursors to
things like midsummer and stuff
this this one a lot of people have
compared it to like an updating of like
rosemary's baby
in the sense that you know there's a
satanic cult or something or like a
black magic evil cult like in new york
city like operating under the radar
um so that kind of thing and this one
also has
um a sort of 80s yuppie thing where it's
like all these kind of like wealthy
you know wealthy white people are kind
of using this sort of santeria kind of
cult to gain power and money and stuff
so there's that kind of aspect to it as
well
but yeah um
this is it's yeah so this was directed
actually by john
schlesinger who had also done probably
most famous for midnight cowboy uh he'd
also done marathon marathon man he did
marathon that's a good flick uh pacific
heights which is uh
we need to do that one i remember that
being really good and marathon man check
that out we'll do that we'll do that
marathon man eventually yeah but yeah so
it's the same uh director that did five
days of the condor real similar oh yeah
man i haven't done that yeah robert spy
movie yeah yeah i remember really liking
that yeah real good but yeah so it's
kind of cool because even though this
has a lot of horror elements to it and
the practical effects are really good
and it's like child sacrificial child
murder and [ __ ] like that but
it seemed like it kind of attempted to
make a serious thriller about it you
know what i mean it's not
overtly ridiculous so it's like i don't
know like the vibe of it just reminds me
of like the sharp the serpent of the
rainbow which is like a horror movie but
it's like it tries to um
it tries to treat the subject matter
seriously i guess
and even though
i guess the controversy at the time that
this came out like even back in 87
because like i said this was still
satanic panic times
but
even in 87 like some critics complain
they said well you know a lot of people
practice santeria and you're just making
it look like they're all essentially
devil worshipers and that's kind of
shitty
um even though they do kind of try to
like gloss that over and say well it's
not all this because there is one good
santeria person like a couple of good
santoria people they're like no it's
like black magic and white magic but it
could be forgiven if for watching the
movie and say that the because century
is like a real religion so
yeah it's like makuma yeah
we're going red again
it's going red again i know i see it
okay okay it's back it's back okay it's
back for me
yeah it's back
yeah
santoria is kind of like my kumba
brazil has that macumba yeah similar
yeah it's it's you know it's just kind
of like similar you know
it's kind of like the whole catholicism
this i i kind of feel like santeria is
more like uh you know african cuban type
of organized africanized catholicism
yeah i think makuma is the same way yeah
and then it has kind of like some animal
sacrifice and
[ __ ] like that but it's similar kind of
a similar kind of thing oh oscar perez
is in there pissed off that antlers
wasn't any good told you
and if i mentioned something bad about
antlers we're going to lose the stream
ai's watch it out for it
why would they do that they must have
invested
you two must have a vested interest in
that movie
i don't think so but whatever just let
me [ __ ] let me
let you just make sure yeah okay this is
entertainment
this is entertaining but yeah uh so holy
parish of doom says i can't recall
martin sheen doing too many horror
movies yeah yeah this is really one of
the few that i can i mean he was in a
dead zone yeah um you know that's also
another option
yeah we did that one a long time ago
actually i think that
the acting in this
is my favorite thing about it i just
really really liked
uh particularly the relationship to
martin sheen i mean the story of it is
martin sheen he plays he's like a um
he's like a police psychologist like
when you know when cops have to go
through [ __ ] up [ __ ] like they go to
him to like kind of you know get through
the get through the trauma or whatever
so he's has that job and then that he
has a son and at the beginning he has a
wife
and his wife
uh gets killed in a really
uh
either a way that is going to be like
really kind of
oh my god pokey what the hell um
this is going to be
really kind of
pokey stop attacking the posters oh she
like tore it all up yeah stopping
she's trying she's like you are not
paying attention to me i'm getting mad
that was your cramps poster uh it's not
it's the paper that's behind it oh okay
so it's all right it was it was taped on
some paper it's not the actual poster
although you might want to take it away
from her anyway because she might get
the ideas
she's like oh i just finished it
it was already great okay i see what
you're doing okay
she's like what i didn't do anything she
sees it rip she's going to want to
finish the rip yeah well i get that now
she's laying down
like like job well done okay
rips the [ __ ] out of that
but yeah so at the beginning and this is
actually one of the scenes that i had
remembered like from the old days
because actually some people think this
scene is like really funny which i guess
it sort of is but if you think about
that really happening to you or thinking
about a loved one
and that happening to them like right in
front of you it's probably not as funny
because basically what happens
um to his wife is that they're all in
the kitchen like doing family [ __ ] or
whatever and then martin sheen like
pulls the milk carton or is pulled
pulling something out of the fridge and
spills milk all over the floor like you
do
and then like his wife goes to clean it
up and then she notices that the coffee
pot is on the fritz and she goes over
and touches the coffee pot
but there's milk all over the floor and
it electrocutes her so she's basically
just like standing there getting
electrocuted and i will admit that like
like i said this kind of freaked me out
when i was younger like when i was a
teenager because i'm like oh man how
much would that suck like that [ __ ]
happening or like you seeing that happen
to your mom and like there's nothing you
could do about it that'd be pretty
[ __ ] up so i did like remember that
but then when i was watching it last
night i was kind of like martin sheen
comes in and of course he's like
flipping out i'm like oh my god get a
brim handle docker
i don't know if that would have helped
or not but uh but yeah so she dies
so i guess at that point this is like
the very very beginning of the movie and
the very uh so then they i guess they
lived in minneapolis and then they moved
back to new york city where he had gone
to college and he starts getting a job
there and then basically he gets sucked
into this whole cult situation
because a cop named tom lopez who's
played by jimmy smits he's great in this
too by the way he's not a huge part but
he's really good in it um he was working
undercover with one of these cults and i
guess they found out
that he was a cop
and basically cursed him so he's kind of
like at the scene where they find this
dead kid with all of this you know
cult paraphernalia
and uh and he's like and tom lopez is
like losing his [ __ ] mind because
like now the cult know who i am and
they're gonna do all this black magic
[ __ ] to me and so of course they think
he's a nut so they bring in
martin sheen's character to like be like
hey can you like talk him down from the
ledge please and uh so then all kind of
[ __ ] ensues where he gets sucked into
this world of this black magic which
actually does turn out to be real i mean
you know like he actually does end up
because isn't his thing like he thinks
his stomach is full of snakes like
that's what he tells everybody and then
when they when he dies and they do he
actually ends up stabbing himself and
then like they do the autopsy and his
insides are all covered with snakes
so he was actually right there they
didn't put like snakes inside him like
secretly
you know what i mean like or magically
they'd put a curse on him it's basically
this one dude
this creepy looking dude named
what was his name paulo paulo something
like that and he um
stopped at pogba yeah what the hell she
is just like being what okay i'm
come on i have like a couple posters
over there that i haven't got underneath
but i haven't got frames for yet and
she's just kind of like she tore off the
that that was just the backing that
wasn't the actual poster i grabbed a red
pillow and just started putting it
behind her like that when it touched her
when it touched her [ __ ] back foot
she turned around and saw this big red
pillow and she went whoa and jumped
straight up and then ran
oh [ __ ] well she knows she's in trouble
yeah you don't have to punish her you
just have to [ __ ] start creeping up
on her
zod she runs well because she wants you
she wants me to chase her yeah she wants
people well that's why she does that
she's not doing it just to be a brat
she's doing it because she's like hey
come she's bored yeah come play with me
yeah oh holy parish of doom also points
out that martin sheen was in uh the
little girl who lives down the lane
that's right we just we reviewed that
not too long ago too i had forgotten he
was in that yeah he played the pedo yeah
yeah he was super creepy in there yeah
cause she and you could tell like as
soon as he came over to the house like
with that face i was just like oh man
that's like that's a creep and a half
right there but uh but yeah so so
basically they like
this whole he gets embroiled in this
whole cult [ __ ] and
one one of the things too is that yeah
paulo is this guy who comes over and
he's got like uh he's at this party with
all these kind of like rich white people
or whatever and he starts doing this
weird ass dance like in the middle of
the
thing and his eyes are all rolling back
white and stuff like i said very serpent
in the rainbow and i guess he was i
didn't get this until like i read the
the summation of the movie but he was
trying to get
that woman's necklace because martin
sheen like he's like his wife died
obviously like how i think it's nine
months before or whatever and he starts
a relationship with his landlady who
lives across the street
and so they kind of start getting
together
and
so then they go to this party and this
guy is like trying to get her necklace
but what happens before that
is that she leaves her
uh makeup compact in the bathroom and he
goes in there like she leaves it there
and then like he goes in there and kind
of like touches it and like puts a curse
on it and then later when she's using it
she has some like crazy urban legend
[ __ ] happened to her where
that's a pretty famous urban legend
where you get like that zit on your face
and it gets bigger and bigger and bigger
and then it busts and a bunch of spiders
come out um
yeah yeah so they do that in this movie
and when i was watching that one scene
because i remembered that part and i was
just kind of like oh man i forgot how
[ __ ] good that looked because they
really had to do that they don't have
cgi like it wasn't little cgi spiders
running all over that poor woman's face
they really had to do that those were
real ass spiders they were kind of like
crawling up by her eye and [ __ ] like
that and i'm like man i hope she got
[ __ ] hazard pay for that [ __ ] holy
crap that was like [ __ ] scary but um
yeah so you had you ever seen this movie
yeah i saw a long time ago but i forgot
all about it yeah it was kind of one of
those ones that like you know a lot of
these at that time yeah i don't think
it's as good as serpent of the rainbow
or angel heart
but it's
but it's definitely good and it's
definitely worth watching it just seems
like one that a lot of people forgot
about there was a certain genre of
movies that was coming out in that
period and they came out for a while
about five years of these movies maybe
six years of them
and this is up there with them but it's
not one of the real memorable ones
uh if you if you've never seen anything
from this kind of period this genre you
want to see angel heart or serpent the
rainbow first
uh there's a couple of other ones that
were better too wasn't there one's okay
once you get the hang of it and what
they're trying to do they have this look
and this tone and the same kind of
topics
this one fits right in there with them
it's just not one of the first ones you
want to see
yeah it's kind of yeah it's kind of like
a second tier one but it's still totally
worth watching and like i said i think
that the acting performances are what
really elevates this one because like
not only is martin sheen great in this
um helen [ __ ] i can't remember the kid
that plays his kid but the interaction
between martin sheen and that kid is
really um
natural i mean they really you really do
buy that they're father and son yeah uh
so that kid is great um [ __ ] robert
loja is in this he's fantastic he's like
the the chief of police or the sheriff
or whatever
and um uh who else was i gonna say oh
the guy that plays what the [ __ ] is that
actor's name he
you know if you saw him he's in
everything he's like a character actor
that plays like his
friend and his lawyer that dude is also
great like he's just kind of like this
funny you know and he's also very like
naturalistic so i really like
all of the acting performances in this
which really really kind of make this
a lot better because you really kind of
feel for this
family and those like there's all kind
of like family drama going on with like
the dad and the girl new girlfriend and
the kid doesn't want a replacement for
his mom and it all comes across as like
very
realistic but it's not
it's not so much family drama that it
bogs down the cult [ __ ] because there's
cult [ __ ] going on pretty much through
the whole thing
um you know because somebody is cursed
and like some bad [ __ ] is happening
through the whole thing and then it
turns out too that
this um
that kind of rich white guy who's sort
of the um you know the the benefactor of
this play it's set in spanish harlem
and uh he actually he's kind of the head
of this cult and he brought this paulo
dude over
from africa i guess and he's like saying
yeah what we do is every now and then is
we sacrifice every one of them has to
sacrifice their son
right like they have to sacrifice one of
their sons uh to get like all this
wealth and power
and so he's been able to convince like a
lot of these kind of like high up elite
people to
do that like to sacrifice their own kids
like so they can get power like you know
through the curse and everything but
like i said there it's based on a novel
which i've never actually read the novel
came out in 1982 and the novel was just
called the religion
and like i said in this one they very
specifically
identify it as santeria
but
you know i i don't know like because
they do kind of say that it's like oh
you know not everybody practices century
is bad obviously it's kind of like i
kind of feel like that happened with
voodoo a lot like in the old days where
you'd put voodoo in a movie and
everybody would just automatically be
like oh well voodoo's bad even though
millions of people
follow that religion and obviously it's
not you know everybody's not bad so i
kind of feel like this had a little bit
of that but it did have
um the character of carmen who was
martin sheen's maid she also practiced
santeria but she was actually really
trying to protect
the kid because she knew what was going
on so she was trying to do like white
magic to counteract it but she wasn't
like powerful enough but then before
martin sheen
like um
realized that the [ __ ] was real
he like uh he kind of did her dirty
honestly because he was just kind of
like you get the sh get all this [ __ ]
out of my house and
stuff like that like all the candles and
stuff and i'm like seriously i wasn't
really hurting anything but okay and um
you know she was just trying to protect
the kid and i kind of feel like i kind
of wish that there had been a scene at
the end where he went back to because he
fired her right that was his housekeeper
i was like if he had gone and gone back
and been like sorry you were right
you could have your job back because
she's like unemployed now i don't know
that's just something that i thought of
one thing that i didn't love i mean i do
actually really like this movie like i
said it's kind of like
a second tier one as far as this type of
thing goes but it's still totally worth
watching and i feel like a lot of people
don't really talk about it
but one thing i didn't love was i
thought the end
was a little too
not abrupt it's not abrupt but i felt
like it should have been fleshed out a
little bit more because i didn't really
like the way that paulo
who was kind of like
i don't think he well he wasn't
necessarily the main villain he was kind
of like because i kind of feel like that
one that one dude whatever that dude's
name was that that one kind of guy no no
the other guy the white guy the bald old
white guy
calder was that his name
um the benefactor guy yeah um i kind of
feel like he was the main villain
because he was kind of like the impetus
behind it he was the reason that paulo
came there and [ __ ] like that so it's
almost kind of like paulo was like his
i don't know like his attack dog or his
helper or something like that i'm not
really sure like what you would call it
but he just brought him over there like
to do curses and [ __ ] on people
so but i didn't really like
the way
that paulo
died or was defeated at the end it just
seemed a little bit
not i don't know it i felt like it
needed a little bit more
that's all i was not complaining too
much because it's actually like a decent
ending but i just kind of thought that
it needed a little bit more to it it was
a movie of its time yeah um the audience
expectations were very different people
had longer attention spans it didn't
require a bunch of yelling and a bunch
of action scenes every five seconds like
one of these modern star trek movies
where you spock yelling and [ __ ] it's
just
boxes
and he's yelling and
do these people know star trek
spock doesn't yell
yeah he doesn't do star trek he doesn't
announce no i know but i i was just
saying and the old ones yeah it's
because because you know that's kind of
one well the audiences today would find
spock boring so we're going to make that
[ __ ] yell and beat kirk's ass
which that happens in the movies too
just [ __ ] ridiculous all right track
is track old track is track william
shatner's trip all right
that's right um
i don't want to go down for the star
trek thing but anyway the uh
it was just a movie of its time they
were kinda
they took their time they weren't slow
not as slow as a 70s movie
but they were trying to get a lot of
tone and there was a lot of visual tone
to it and a lot of emotional tone and
they tried to do as much as they
possibly could with dialogue so the
acting tends to be pretty good
um oh okay it came back so the acting
tends to be pretty good because they
were trying to do as much as they could
just with dialogue they lost whatever
they
but um
they're just the movies of the time yeah
real stylish when this came out i
remember when these movies were coming
out remember when this one came out they
seemed very futuristic at the time
because they just weren't like other
movies from the 80s the mid 80s they
cleaned up a lot in terms of just like
how the camera work was done the quality
was it was bad you now had
good actors doing this kind of material
because this kind of material started to
become more respectable
yeah that's what i was going to say
because this really seemed like because
i kind of feel like the 80s particularly
when you talk about horror um you know a
lot of it was slasher movies obviously
there was different types of movies too
but overwhelmingly it was slasher movies
and i kind of feel like for the first
part of the 80s particularly horror was
kind of seen as more like a teenage boy
kind of thing whereas this one was kind
of harkening back to the 70s where you
kind of had these prestige
horror films with actually kind of like
a-list actors and they actually took the
material seriously it wasn't just like
silly or it wasn't it was an adult
horror movie yeah the reason why is
because it was my generation and the
guys a little bit older than me were now
graduating from high school or there you
now had a job but you grew up watching
those early
80s movies
so it's the same audience now just older
yeah and older now and they're they're
they're refining everything
the old audience that that they were
playing to in the mid 80s in the early
80s had aged out by this time so they're
like well we don't have to worry about
those old fuddy duddies we'll take our
good actors and we'll [ __ ] have them
do a horror movie because that's what
that's what the kids we were [ __ ]
with in the early 80s they're growing up
now they got mo they got money
that's what it is so yeah they got money
now so they'll go they'll come see this
in the theater
and they were you were going to see
angel hart in the theater and [ __ ] uh
uh rainbow in the surf but i saw that
one in the theater
i think i did too yeah so because we had
the money to go that came out about a
year after this one i think yeah i came
out after this one right angel the
serpent was was better serpent in the
rainbow in the rainbow i mean yes uh
angel i read that raven was better yeah
looking um
you know we were talking about it
afterwards and stuff it was just
this was a period where horror was
starting to elevate it was selling a lot
at blockbuster on vhs
and you could
now get people to go into a theater and
see it even if it was r-rated they'd go
in there and see it
and they made money the budgets weren't
as big not like today you know what i
mean but they would go in there and see
it and then it would be like the thing
of the month people talk about it
you weren't competing against the
internet
yeah let's see so i thought this one
made a pretty i don't think it made a
[ __ ] ton of money but it didn't cost
that much to make so i think it made a
pretty respectable like financial
showing yeah and i was gonna say too
that movies like this i think it kind of
might have helped because only three
years later uh something that was
essentially a horror movie silence of
the lambs yeah swept the oscars yeah
only three years after this yeah that
never would have happened in the early
80s i remember being being blown away
that was the year i graduated high
school and i remember being blown away
by
that winning the oscar i'm like holy
[ __ ] that's because it's a horror movie
okay i'm sorry that's a horror movie
yeah that never would have happened they
call it a thriller but that never would
have happened like my parents generation
no way would have never [ __ ] made it
yeah it was just they had people had
better taste
caspy yeah i mean the more adventurous
taste in things yeah i mean i do kind of
feel like like i said this isn't the
best example of the genre but
i like that there were there i guess
it's kind of like cyclical because like
i said in the 70s you had prestige
horror movies you like don't look now
rosemary's baby the exorcist that were
not that were you know adult themed
horror movies that adults could go see
and it didn't feel like a stupid teenage
whatever but then like in the 80s i kind
of felt like horror went
in a more juvenile direction which like
in a lot of ways you could say like it
went in a more fun direction yeah that
was fun too which yeah that was fun too
it just depends on what you like want
yeah those movies did well at
blockbuster yes they did real well we
[ __ ] loved them
but i honestly like both kinds and i
kind of like that you have the option
for both because sometimes i'm in the
mood for just like a dumbass bloody gory
slasher movie and sometimes you want
something a little more mature but that
still has horror elements to it and i
kind of feel like this one is one of
those where like i said all the acting
is fantastic all you know it's it's just
a really good like adult story but then
it has like a lot of really creepy
it's kind of almost more like like i
said more like a thriller or like a
police procedural sort of yeah i would
say the predecessor to these
would have been like
the early stephen king movies they were
also kind of high
caliber even though they were low budget
depending on which one you're talking
about
but i was mostly looking at like fire
starter and dead zone yeah
they were kind of respectable in their
days yeah like mainstream audience would
see them which was unusual for a horror
movie
um and this movie was kind of like a
more modern from our point of view a
newer more modern version of those
stephen king is actually one of those
not so much with movies because like i
said they did have you know adult horror
movies in the 70s but stephen king
seemed like kind of the first guy to
break through who would break through to
like to mainstream audiences because
prior to that you kind of had horror was
kind of like its own thing like your
paperbacks over there and you had to
kind of be into that to read them you
didn't really get a lot of crossover
with just like grandmas and stuff like
reading the [ __ ] but everybody read
stephen king everybody dead zone and
fire starters were not big budget movies
but they were excellent if you haven't
seen them go back and watch them they're
really good yeah i feel like we did dead
zone have we done fire starter yet i
don't know i thought we did fire starter
but i have to go back so we've done so
many we saw it recently you know and it
still kind of has kind of a low budget
vibe but it still tells that story well
and it's still entertaining to watch if
you've never seen them you know if
you're especially the younger generation
go see those those are good flicks and
well and if your fans at 13 o'clock a
lot of the things that we talked about
are discussed in those they're basically
psychic abilities and the in the realm
of the paranormal from the from the
aspect of parapsychology they're all
about parapsychology
which
back in the 60s and 70s that was a huge
topic
you know yeah i remember that my aunts
were all into that oh yeah and you know
big universities were doing studies on
it
and
they believed it and evidently some of
those some of them
got some supporting evidence um nowadays
that [ __ ] could all be faked it was
harder to fake that kind of stuff back
then it's just out of vogue it was
nowadays that was something kind of like
along the lines of say like spiritism in
the 1800s it was like that yeah but 60s
and 70s big into parapsychology
and um
those movies
came out of that and they put kind of a
horror spin on it but they weren't alone
there was a lot of other movies that
were like that they were coming from the
parapsychology angle
like altered states it was like that uh
what else would come from the para
psychology um
the changeling a little bit yeah that
kind of had a little bit of a
seance or parapsychology kind of thing
going on there was a lot of them though
that were like that
so well uh carrie yeah that too she's
got our spk you know recurrent
spontaneous spot
spontaneous psychokinesis and stuff
um
and that's because
king was into that
yeah so that that was his subject matter
the shining
is parapsychology parapsychology
basically
from a certain limited viewpoint but
yeah
ghosts ghosts and psychic abilities
i mean and if we're talking about
stephen king adaptations from the 80s uh
i got to give a shout out to christine
because yeah i kind of feel like even
though it's john carpenter a lot of
people don't talk about that as being a
really good stephen king adaptation but
i actually commercially that's probably
carpenter's masterpiece artistically the
thing is
that's well yeah obviously i don't think
you get too much argument and then i
just got a real soft spot of course for
escape from new york
i do too yeah well because that's an
awesome movie that's why yeah it's just
it's just so strange
yeah i mean that they made that at that
time
and it's a low-budget movie that looks
really really good because they knew
where to film it
it's just a good flick and it's not a
action film and it's not what is that
it's just kind of an adventure film i
guess yeah
uh because it's not action there's not a
whole lot of action it just goes to show
something how it doesn't have to be one
thing yeah another yeah it's just a
weird you can cross genres okay yeah and
over time i've kind of softened up a
little bit to escape from la it's kind
of like a
tongue-in-cheek
version of escape from new york
but it does have some good things in it
it's just
they wanted it to be very different from
escape from new york they wanted to be
colorful like la and
it's like there's a lot missing in that
and then there's a bunch of stuff in
there that they shouldn't have put in
there i think it's just too goofy but
they did what they did you know
i don't think they took it too seriously
they just wanted to have fun
which i guess that's what it was fair
enough yeah
yeah kevin donovan says uh that led to
satanic panic yeah and this movie is
really kind of like well that's kind of
what's interesting about this one too is
that
it definitely trades in that satanic
panic fear because this is still 87 and
satanic panic was still going until the
early 90s at least or maybe even the mid
90s from what i can remember but this
one even though
it has like i said it has a little bit
of that shade like oh people that
practice santeria are bad or like into
black magic even though they kind of
give a little stop to no they're not all
bad you know because there are a couple
good ones in there i would say satanic
panic was directly related to the
exorcist and amityville horror oh yeah
big time both of those those stories
mention parapsychology there's a
parapsychology angle into it remember
uh the father what's his name father
what's his name the guy who did the
thing for exorcist the guy who did the
original
he mentioned well the parapsychologists
you know think that this is not a real
uh
not a real possession that it's it's
more like it's like you know
psychokinesis or it's a mental problem
because that wasn't holy water remember
they did that test yeah on the demon the
so-called demon so they knew about
parapsychology and they were lincoln
parapsychology with the paranormal and
paranormal stuff
and demons
and ghosts
way back then
so it was just
it was the [ __ ] gestalt of the time
you know i remember it it was a good
time actually but what i what i was uh
where i was going with that was um
was that now i can't even remember
um
i'm sure it wasn't important
but
yeah no i was gonna say that this one
although it kind of does trade in that
fear and outrage that was kind of all
going around like about satanic panic it
did actually kind of take it seriously
even though it kind of indulged in a
little bit but yeah it's not not to a
hysterical degree now
if you guys okay cause wasn't there am i
high or was there another um there was
another movie
and it was called
the first power was that what it was
called blue diamond phillips was there
yeah was that similar to this i kind of
feel like wasn't he a cop
and he was investigating like satanic
cult murders i haven't seen it in like
like 20 or 30 years
i remember it being like this
yeah i kind of remember like conflating
these two and not confusing them for
each other but
putting them together the first power
the one where it opens up was there's
somebody's
sacrificing a goat in a dam in a damn
new york apartment and it looks all
[ __ ] morbid but then the lawyers say
hey
sacrifices to go boom and then they just
throw down some goat tenderloin and they
say it's just livestock
you know we do this all the time isn't
that that same it might be it might and
it got into it got into all the uh the
makumba [ __ ] santeria angle i think i
think it was see it's been like i said i
don't want to say too much because i
can't but i just remember
i remember the poster yeah and like with
lou diamond phillips on it with a gun
and it had like you know a
pentagram on it like a pentagram on it
or something yeah so i did and i
definitely remember he was like a cop i
thought yeah because i remember kind of
like conflating these two i remember
this one being better
but i haven't seen that one in a really
long time and i and i'm so i'm not sure
exactly what it's about but i think it
was like a similar type of
plot to this one maybe it's funny too
because in this movie uh with robert
loja and he plays um the kind of the
sheriff or whatever the guy that's
investigating it i think he has a line
in there too and i kind of thought this
when you saying that about the goat
reminded me but it's he's kind of like
you know killing chickens or sacrificing
chickens isn't religion or something
like that i'm like but you probably eat
chickens though so
i mean i'm not real i'm not i don't know
i i i don't i don't love the idea of
like just sacrificing chickens just for
that but it's like if you're gonna eat
them afterward then as long as they're
not suffering i don't really have that
much of a problem i used to go to those
macumba things every now and again in
brazil when i lived there as a kid you
know remember i told the story that my
friend was a taxi driver used to go to
those things
yeah and he let me go just to see
and it was there wasn't anything scary
about it when we walked in they had a
bunch of chickens on a big old long
wrought iron spike people were going in
i don't think they stuck it on there
alive i think they killed it first and
then and then stuck it on there because
i didn't see them actually go on
but uh no to me it was obvious that
after everybody leaves that he eats
those
yeah that's you know what i mean it's
they say it's offering to the spirits
but it's more like an offer an offering
to the priest
well yeah i mean i'm that's kind of like
the whole thing with like offering to
the spirits or whatever yeah it's kind
of like giving them food it's so you
know yeah but in reality if you're
giving food to the priest yeah he eats
it
i believe he's like well i'm eating i'm
eating it and then like i'm spiritually
getting engaged in the channel and all
this stuff and then he had all these
girls dancing and they were channeling
and they were just having a good time
really you know i mean it's a religious
service just like any other religious
service it felt like
you know
kind of like one of those christian
state cults or you know what drinking
the poison and putting on a show or
[ __ ] talking in tongues to me that's all
putting on a show
i never believed any of it
as fixiamzeen said the movie you were
talking about was the devil's advocate
oh yeah
yeah although i kind of feel like that
one was kind of like satanic it was
hammier
it's been a long time since i've seen it
um i still kind of liked it i think i
saw that in the theater actually yeah
they were all like this kinda
yeah now that i'm thinking about it god
damn there were a lot a lot of them
around this time period and didn't we we
also talked about the ninth gate right
the roman polanski one which i think it
came out like a few years after this i
think yeah
that was early to midnight that was a
good one too didn't that who that who'd
that have in it johnny depp johnny depp
yeah yeah it was good like i said it was
roman polanski not not roman polanski's
best film but it's it's decent it's
still okay and uh you know and i'd want
to read the book but yeah there were a
lot of satanic it's weird because like i
said it's all cyclical like all that
[ __ ] came out in the 70s like extra
sister rosemary's baby and the omen and
all that and then it kind of went away
for a while and then the late 70s or the
late 80s early 90s was kind of like more
satanic movies again and now i kind of
feel like we're seeing
them again like there's a [ __ ] glut
of possession movies and what's that one
i keep seeing the um this trailer for
one that's coming out early next year
called the devil's light it doesn't look
that good but because i was just kind of
like really another like exorcism
possession movie do we really need
anything i remember these things going
it's like you said they started in the
late 80s and they went all the way up
into the 90s and it was about the mid
90s when they stopped and they stopped
because [ __ ] what because of i'd wise
[ __ ] that's right that's my chat my
bride's wide shot with that [ __ ] uh
uh oh what's his name
talkers no no yeah not time to the
director that [ __ ] stanley kubrick
yeah stanley cooper i see i remember
this but i forget the stupid [ __ ]
when stanley kubrick starts going that
way he just like topped all that cult
stuff and then that was it
nobody tried it anymore he like
dropped and and it stopped a lot of
these kind of movies i don't remember
these i don't remember movies like this
happening after eyes watched yeah well
it might have been that's why it was a
[ __ ] blockbuster the way i remembered
it
everybody liked it
it was impressed i remember it got kind
of mixed reviews when it came out
because i remember seeing in the theater
and i liked it but i didn't love it i
appreciate it more now that i've seen it
a bunch more times
um it's still not my favorite movie of
his by a long stretch but um i like it a
lot more than when i saw it the first
time i remember people talking about it
and and telling everybody to see it see
that's how that was my perception of how
well of how it was received i remember
people saying oh that was a weird ass
movie because to annoy me it was weird
yeah maybe that maybe that's why i was
just kind of like i wanted it to be
weirder than it was
i expected it to be weirder to ignore me
that was weird and it didn't seem that
weird to me that's because you're a
[ __ ] you were watching yeah that's what
i mean so to me i was just kind of like
all right mainstream people went to go
see that movie and it scared them and
they're like what yeah i was just kind
of like yeah all right yeah it's a i
don't know but uh yeah devil's advocate
that's another one that i have that
didn't that was the one with um first
power devil's advocate what else are
some other ones that we need to see
louis says i remember the first power
cool movie yeah i'm gonna see i'm gonna
have to see that again because i
remember seeing it probably a couple
times on cable back in the day but i and
i remember it being good but i think i
liked this one better but i haven't seen
that one in such a long time
um
in the first power the villain is
sacrificing a woman yeah
uh holy parish of doom says another good
one with martin sheen his first movie
and not a horror flick is the incident
where he's a street tough harassing
people in new york subway you know what
i don't think i've ever seen that
i might i might actually have to see
that that sounds kind of good
yeah tammy says sacrificing the soul of
the animals to the gods and the body to
the priest yeah that's like that's a
good way of putting it because you know
it's you don't want it all you don't
want all the food going away and that
[ __ ] goes back all the way to the
[ __ ] old testament times because you
know
records say that you know that
roman records say that those [ __ ]
priests were all real well fed
suspiciously and [ __ ] like that because
why are they all so fat yeah
that [ __ ] but they were all [ __ ] well
[ __ ] stopped well and i'm sure and
like i said i would argue it's like well
what are you gonna do just like sit
there and let it all rot yeah it's like
you know what i mean that's dumb they
were they were referring to like um
to the ancient jews like in judea
or i think that was the word that the
romans used for it i'm not sure
um and they were just it was supposed to
be burnt offerings and there wasn't one
what's funny is that a lot of people
think that in ancient in the ancient
history of judea
uh that there was one judaism no there
wasn't it was just like the roman
religion there was a bunch of different
cults of it they were had ashura poles
and they worshiped various gods it was
not a
a monotheistic religion they had a
father of the gods but then they were
all his sons and his wife and their
children the demigods it was just a kind
of like a a hillbilly version of the
[ __ ] roman religion
and uh there was supposed to be
they were supposed to be uh giving birth
offerings and stuff to the guy there's
to burn it all up
but then some people say well no it was
really just the bones they were supposed
to burn what happened to the meat
you know
it's just funny because the the romans
the romans would admit that it was okay
to eat
animal sacrifice to the gods and
christians had to make new rules
is and the rules were basically the
christians the early christians were
asking their church fathers is it okay
to go to a roman's house
and eat meat there and we know that
earlier that that meat had been
sacrificed to their gods is that okay
and the general response was as well we
know that their gods don't exist so of
course it's okay
shout out just eat the burger and calm
down yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they were more reasonable than
people think but they were constantly
worried about what the rules were it
wasn't the christians just the
christians it was all of them they were
all worried about what the rules were
they're like oh my god god's gonna like
hit me lightning if i do something wrong
yeah and everybody was what a horrible
way to live and everybody was worried
about their gods and what their gods
would think you know and and in their
god's interactions with other people's
gods how did that work out whose gods
are above others gods quite fascinating
actually robert price talks a lot about
it we've had him on the show before well
like i said it's not like
not like they did they didn't have
enough like real life [ __ ] to worry
about and then they had to stack all
that [ __ ] on top of it too well that's
how they saw life through that land i
know but what's funny is that they they
they saw the world they saw their gods
kind of like the way we would see like
the mcu
and dc
you know what i mean hey their shit's dc
our shit's [ __ ] mc who's stronger
iron man or or [ __ ] spider-man yeah
that's pretty much how i've always
perceived all of you yeah you're like
well that's two different universes all
of those doctrinal kind of uh
all the gods are in the [ __ ] they're
all coming out of the roma and they're
all in the heavens
their gods and our gods how does this
[ __ ] work out you know which is that's
you would logically ask that question if
you thought it was kind of that or like
a my dad can beat up your dad type of
thing
[Laughter]
well a lot of times they interpreted it
was [ __ ] like well actually they're the
same gods it's just that they have
different stories for the same god yeah
that's usually that's true they're
trying to get everybody to get along you
know yeah yeah it's the same dude we
just named it something else yeah
zeus and el-shaddai are both fathers of
the gods it's the same one they're just
everybody settled they just they're just
worshiping them in a different way you
know then you'd find temples that were
[ __ ] honored to both of those gods
because they were being seen as the same
god
you'd see that
too yeah
it is very interesting like the
histories of religion yeah
but yeah so uh so yeah this movie the
believers
uh they just added it to amazon prime
like probably like a week ago which is
what gave me the idea to watch it and
like i said i was kind of in the mood to
watch it last night and uh yeah that's
it i i i remembered it being good but
yeah i actually like really enjoyed it
so you know if you liked like i said if
you liked angel heart if you like
serpent the rainbow those type of movies
that came out around this time and you
haven't seen this one then uh go check
it out because it's actually uh totally
it's like i said it's not quite as good
as those but it's totally worth watching
like i said i think the acting is kind
of the strong point in it and it's got
like some glory [ __ ] in it too like some
good practical effects so yeah you know
check it out uh you you done talking
yeah all right so i guess we will be
back tomorrow talking about another
movie probably right around 3 p.m
eastern standard time as usual so thanks
everybody for dropping by we'll see you
guys tomorrow